una acusación explosiva ha puesto al
radar de la censura china a trabajar a
marcha forzada pensó hay una de las
principales estrellas deportivas del
país ha acusado al político sangalli de
cuestionar la a tener relaciones
sexuales hace años todo comenzó con una
publicación de la cuenta verificada de
peng shuai en la gigante red social
china weibo la carta abierta sostiene
que existe una relación con zhang a olli
durante periodos intermitentes que se
extendió por al menos 10 años 20 am bien
acusa al ex vice primer ministro y
miembro del máximo cuerpo de toma de
decisiones del país de forzarlo a tener
sexo hace tres años la publicación fue
borrada a 30 minutos después y detonó
una ola de censura en línea las
búsquedas con el nombre de pena en
portales chinos no muestran resultados y
se ha bloqueado interacciones como
compartir o comentar sobre el post
original en su lugar aparece este
mensaje
lo sentimos no se puede completar esta
acción porque la publicación incluye
contenido que viola las leyes son las
reglas de la comunidad de weibo esto fue
lo que dijo el vocero del ministerio del
exterior cuando se le consultó sobre la
censura
no he oído sobre este tema no es una
cuestión relacionada con asuntos
exteriores próxima pregunta
las autoridades chinas no se han
pronunciado ni se ha hecho cobertura de
las denuncias en medios de comunicación
locales en 2018 el movimiento me tuvo en
china ganó impulso cuando un estudiante
de una universidad de beijing acusó a su
profesor de acoso sexual lo que llegó
hasta las organizaciones no
gubernamentales a la prensa y a la
industria del entretenimiento pero es
primera vez con político importante es
públicamente acusado de forzar
sexualmente a alguien